welcome to the show we're sort of
crossing the Rubicon in a sense on the
topic of impeachment proceedings against
Donald Trump we have a new poll up on
the community tab of the David Pakman
show YouTube channel asking what you
think is going to happen but we now have
sitting senators who are calling for the
impeachment of Donald Trump
not just at political events but on the
Senate floor and I'm talking about
Democratic senator Elizabeth Warren who
is also running for president for the
Democratic nomination in 2020 we've
heard it from the house but this is a
much bigger deal because sitting active
members of the Senate saying on the
Senate floor that it's time for
impeachment proceedings against the
President of the United States to start
is very different than a member of the
House who if with peace and love we
respect and understand are important
members of the American political
establishment this is a senator during
live speeches on the house of the Senate
take a look at Elizabeth Warren
yesterday it's enough here to bring an
impeachment proceeding and forth for us
for this body for Congress to back up
from that and to say that protecting the
president is more important than
protecting the Constitution it's not
only wrong it is a violation of our oath
of office I'm here to say one more time
in publicly this is not a fight I wanted
to take on but this is the fight in
front of us now this is not about
politics this is about the Constitution
of the United States of America we took
an oath not to try to protect Donald
Trump we took an oath to protect the
Contin serve the Constitution of the
United States of America and the way we
do that is we begin impeachment
proceedings now against this president
mr. president I yield the floor
sitting senators calling for impeachment
of a sitting president is a big deal
don't let you know Trump will frame this
as who knows wacky pocahontas or
whatever he likes to say about Elizabeth
Warren remember how
badly Republicans hated Barack Obama I
mean deeply they hated him but they knew
he didn't actually do anything worthy of
impeachment you had Senator John Kyl who
said about President Obama impeachment
is always a possibility
but no one is talking about that he said
that on a radio show about Barack Obama
you had senator james inhofe who's out
of his mind
who said Obama could be impeached over
the suppose did Benghazi cover-up turns
out there was no such cover-up and no
one actually tried to impeach President
Obama for that no senators actually
tried to do that Senator Tom Coburn
during the Obama era said in a political
setting Obama is getting close to having
done enough to justify impeachment it
wasn't true but that was at a town hall
meeting it wasn't on the floor of the
Senate if you go back to george w bush
for example I mean no senators
democratic or republican were saying
it's time to impeach george w bush uh
and the reason why is that senators on
the floor of the senate don't say that a
president should be impeached if they
actually haven't done anything worthy of
it Democratic Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi though as taking a bit of a
different approach
she is further resisting impeachment she
says Trump is goading us to impeach him
and then it would actually help Donald
Trump to solidify his base now I hate to
break it to Nancy Pelosi but Donald
Trump's base is very solid right
twenty-eight percent of the country has
already said they're definitely voting
for Donald Trump in 2020 his base isn't
moving but that's more of a political
calculation that Nancy Pelosi seems to
be making Elizabeth Warren is laying it
out in clearer terms this is not about
politics this is about facts and the law
and the Constitution the the question of
the political strategy is a legitimate
one and I think it's actually a question
as to whether it is good political
strategy to try to impeach Donald Trump
but the actions at this point are there
that's the reality and now that being
said no one should jump the gun on
impeachment step one is just
debate on the floor of the House of
Representatives that it that is just the
first step here
Trump's administration won't even comply
with the most minor oversight requests
for records for documents for testimony
that is part of the obstruction for
which this house floor debate on
impeachment actually should be happening
start the debate have the debate about
impeachment in the house use that to
gather evidence use that to publicize
what it is that has been done use it to
get people to understand what's in the
Moller report because as I've said
before too many Americans simply haven't
read the Moller report and they're
operating sort of under the guise of
this no collusion no obstruction PR
campaign meme that Donald Trump and
William bar have pretty damn
successfully mounted so start the debate
and use the debate in the house to
collect the evidence go where the
evidence takes you but it is time to
formally start the impeachment debate on
the floor of the House of
Representatives period get Robert Muller
to the house and have him answer the
question would Donald Trump be facing
criminal obstruction charges if he was
not President of the United States
Muller will of course give a diplomatic
non-committal answer and say oh that's a
hypothetical but he won't be able to say
no the president would not be facing
obstruction charges if he were not
President of the United States because
the answer is yes Trump would be
indicted for obstruction if he were not
a sitting president good for Elizabeth
Warren for calling it for what it is
let's now see if other senators join her
there are other senators Democratic
senators who are running for president
some of them have said in non Senate
settings that they believe that the time
at least for the debate about
impeachment is here let's hear from
Kamala Harris on the floor of the Senate
let's hear from Cory Booker on the floor
of the Senate and see if we can get
multiple sitting senators saying in open
Senate session it is time to start
impeachment proceedings if not at least
impeachment debate about the President
of the United States do not let Trump
trick you into believing that this is
just no big deal this is very
this doesn't often happen during in
American politics two presidents of the
United States it's a big deal and we're
going to be paying attention to it
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]